[Music]
[Applause]
Mike Breen just called his 100th NBA
Finals game last night joining us from
the Denver Airport
how are you feeling Mike
well every time I come here this is one
of the most extraordinary places in the
entire world the Denver Airport the
magnitude of the of the place the amount
of people yet somehow it works I I can't
understand it it really is it's one of
the great Wonders of the World this
place all right well thank you Mike
that's all we wanted to know we
appreciate your time as always
great to talk to you again
did you realize like we had two teams
that didn't want they wanted to be
underdogs here but
I don't think you guys didn't treat
either one as an underdog and I talked
to Jeff Van Gundy about this but did you
feel like there was an underdog feel to
these two teams in the finals
not in the finals I I thought Denver was
an underdog team despite having the best
record in the west through most of the
western playoffs uh just in the
perception because they still had to
prove that they they were ready to do
that but in the finals after what they
did to the Lakers
um then they were they were no longer on
the drugs Miami certainly was because
you look at their roster
um and I mean it's it's such an
admirable team to root for and they play
so hard and you know the phrase that
they're supposed to keep using the
competitive Spirit uh makes you admire
them so much but they were they were
definitely the underdog in that in the
finals what's it say about this sport
that's the fifth different Champion
we've had in the last five years
I think it's great
um you know we all love the David and
Goliath stories when when one team is
dominant and and we're rooting for
somebody to knock them off their perch
but when you go into a playoff series
and I can't remember the last time I
felt that
there were this many teams that had a
chance to make the finals it's just it's
just great the unpredictability of this
year made it one of my favorite Seasons
just because you didn't know and even
the elite teams they all had small
margins of error and you normally don't
say that about the elite team and they
all had flaws so you couldn't you know
definitively stay although that doesn't
stop a lot of people but you couldn't
definitively say that's the best team or
they're going to win the title because
you just didn't know
I'm wondering if the Joker is messing
with us it like you're around him it it
it it feels like he's having some fun
with us but then I hear the post game
comments he just wants to go home he
doesn't want to go to a parade or any of
that uh is he messing with it or with us
or is that just him
you know that's a great observation
um because I think you might be right he
has so much joy in being with his
teammate and he does seem to enjoy the
banter with the media and I think maybe
just because he knows he's messing with
us I I can't remember the last time I
saw a player who combined
you know clearly he wants to just be
with his family and his teammates have
told us that you know they've said when
when the season's over when practice is
over he just can't wait to get home to
his daughter and his wife and that's
genuine but at the same time
he is so competitive and so loves to win
and loves to win
because his team is all connected
um it's a very interesting combination
like I thought I watched him and the way
he handles himself and the way he talks
you know what he's going to one day
we're gonna wake up and he's going to
say I'm done yeah
but then again he loves that whole team
aspect of the sport that he might not
want to be done because I think he takes
such great enjoyment for that
yeah I think he loves the game I don't
think he likes the ancillary stuff and
then I could see him one day like in
three or four years just say that's it
it's not like Andrew Luck who was
injured and didn't reach the Pinnacle
playing for a Super Bowl the Joker's
done he's you know two MVPs and he's won
a title he's got five years left on his
contract I wouldn't be surprised if he
walked away after that we're talking to
Mike brain ESPN ABC NBA play by play
voice the first time you said Bang
was when and where did it come from
okay because I used to say it off the
air when I was a Fordham student I went
to pretty much every sport and
basketball game Tom penders was the
coach there and Fordham was good
um and I went to all the games and if a
Fordham player hit a shot I screamed it
out in the stand so that's what gave me
the thought maybe I'll try that on the
air when I started doing College radio
when I was a student at Fordham so
that's that's the origin of it and and
kind of the reason I stuck with it was
because
in a big moment when the crowd's going
crazy
um you know the human voice is really
not made to override a crowd and to try
and do that I don't have one of those
great deep Marathon voices that someone
else's house but uh for me to be able to
make a concise call and not have to
override a crowd and get out of the way
and let the crowd enhance the moment I
thought that was a good word nice one
syllable word to say it and get the hell
out of the way I thought that you came
into National prominence it was Steph
Curry hitting that deep deep three
against Oklahoma City that's the first
time I felt like it resonated with
everybody basketball fans
did that was that significant in your
mind when Steph hits that really long
three and then you you gave us a bang
I think not only that one but a number
of other ones that Steph Curry I feel
he's responsible for for a lot of my uh
notoriety so to speak and um no I would
agree with that I think that's another
excellent observation although when I
when I hear that call back sometimes I
just think who is this screaming fool
because it's I just got so caught up it
really wasn't out of body experience and
it's just I love the game so much and
when you see players doing these
extraordinary things I I can't help but
get crazy and excited because uh you
know again it's just the passion for the
game uh Ray Allen shot too was uh
another one that was a national
landscape stuff when he you know you're
doing one with the NBA Finals
um and by the way I was wondering about
this if you had a shooting contest with
you Mark Jackson and Jeff Van Gundy
I think I'm taking you
well depends on the Range I have I don't
have three-point range but I'll stand up
to anybody from 17 feet and in of those
two now Jeff is sneaking good sneaky
good and of course uh from what I
understand Mark was a player at some
point
three U.S the three of us yeah who would
win all three of us would say oh I'd win
all three
this might be this actually might be a
good thing to do a context to finally
settle at once and for all I would call
it and I would uh you know whoever hit
the game winner of course I would yell
out Bang
[Laughter]
we'll have to get on this this could be
this could be something interesting did
you get to take part in the celebration
last night
I feel I did by just sitting there uh we
were all saying after the game now you
know we've had the
great Fortune of being around a lot and
seeing a lot of these Championship
celebrations that that was one of my
favorites there was just a feeling of of
joy
um and you know when it's the first
title ever it's always something special
uh when it hasn't happened in a long
time it's always something special but
there was something about it and maybe
it was because of the um the group that
that won it there's such a likable group
including the head coach and Michael
Malone I've known since since I was like
28 years old so that was all kind of
part of scene but when you see and I say
it every year though when you see these
players act like little kids you know
these millionaires who are stars and
celebrities and they just get they get
cut down to being little kids jumping
for joy it's um it's a great great thing
to see
a lot of fun as always thank you Mike
safe travels back home
all right Daniel always a pleasure bud
that's uh Mike Breen played by play
voice ESPN ABC that was the 100th NBA
Finals game that he has caught
and he's a Hall of Famer